Ariana Huffington she's the founder of
The Huffington Post she collapsed from
exhaustion in 2007. she was at home on
the phone she's checking her emails when
she passed out fell and woke up in a
pool of blood with a broken cheekbone
and a cut over her eye and it was a
wake-up call for her but she actually
realized what she wasn't sleeping enough
she wrote a book called a Sleep
Revolution because she wanted to build a
business she wanted to make an impact
she wanted to hustle and she was but
fatigue in Burnout knocked her down and
it's a weird tension because on one hand
we have to hustle we have to work hard
but on the other hand we have to be
careful because we don't want to fall
into fatigue and burnout